Ron DeSantis is now trying to cut LGBT
subject matter from an advanced
placement psychology class that is
taught in Florida as an optional class
and the College Board good for them is
saying no the bigger story here well
there's really two stories here there's
three stories there's 12 no there's
three as far as I can tell one is the
subject matter in the curriculum of this
advanced placement psychology class
which we'll talk about in a moment the
second part of it is the continued quote
anti-woke war that Ron DeSantis is
fighting in the State of Florida and
thirdly is that this is yet another
example of how right-wingers claim to
have a particular value but then as soon
as that value is inconvenient they
abandon it and I will tell you about
that in a moment and it has everything
to do with this subject matter being in
a psychology class which based on their
previous statements is something you
would think they would be okay with